hello hi we are gonna be playing some
carried away today which is a game
that's been often requested hello
everybody welcome out there if you guys
remember a game called poly bridge this
game might be kind of like that one
I'm not harbor isn't sure and I probably
should go through the tutorial shouldn't
I
you know what just in case I'm gonna do
that okay go
hello oh do I actually have to select it
that prolly probably important okay so
this game where you're trying to make a
ski-lift and if you don't make it right
people die I'm assuming
welcome to the rookie mountains my name
is Jimmy and I'm gonna teach you the
lost art of chairlift construction let's
get going
my last apprentice built this chairlift
but he's uh he's no longer with us I
think that means he's dead very
extremely dead we're gonna need some
wheels to support the rope select the
wheel material and place out on top of
the existing tower okay all right great
now grab the orange rope handle and drag
it to the other side of the chairlift
station okay time to test this beauty
all right ah whoa 3d hey don't worry
you're gonna you're not gonna die
probably you know horrible monsters
accident oh no it was wonderful oh yeah
[ __ ] oh my god
wait no there's no cliff there's no
cliff it just goes off into nothingness
goes into a frozen lake where they just
die I'll go for syndicator
all right sure that's good force okay
next what a relief you've already made
it further than my last apprentice
now the question remains did that
Prentice is he no longer with us because
like he died in an accident or you
killed him Jimmy because if I'm not
mistaken maybe you're sure wasn't read
the first time you wore that if you know
what I mean it select the plank building
materials to cheapest and weakest
material for chairlift construction I
couldn't agree more I literally cannot
agree any more than I already am
agreeing with you buddy God you are the
smartest handsomest dude I've ever seen
in my life oh that's handy dandy Randy
football okay don't forget about wheels
and ropes sure whatever
long bling lamp no that's ring around
the rosey the wrong way all right there
we go test that bad boy mmm ah that's
good [ __ ] oh no I don't like the color
is all right it's good it's cool it's
cool all right let's see level tree no
that means but okay this tower doesn't
look right I wonder why
all right let's repair it right-click on
the node to drag it to a new location
okey-dokey then
okey-dokey then alright yep this is safe
okay uh we're going do bleh
Oh we're gonna build a wait that doesn't
look right Jimmy you're leading me
astray here you [ __ ]
all right Jimmy else we got here I got
hungry and ate the blueprints Jimmy I'm
thinking you got hungry and ate your
last apprentice I don't know what you're
talking about over here Jimmy so you're
gonna have to build this one on your own
all right okay use the spacebar to
switch between builder and simulation
modes if you don't succeed the first
time you can select the towers using the
tower selection tool alrighty then you
know what I'm gonna build this old mono
e mono style which is uh I'm a
grandpappy used to do it back in the old
days there get like a box structure
going on here try everybody needs to
trust me I was I used to be an engineer
maybe in a past life all right yep no
that's not quite right yeah I wait there
we go nope yeah yeah yeah okay move this
down football-sized all right cool yeah
everybody happy with this no can't
imagine why what are you talking about
proper construction and the such as like
as that goop all right hope nobody died
oh what's the worst that could happen
people die a horrible death and then
everything but everybody's dead yeah
that's a lot of force you know if you
could stop bouncing on the ski lift that
would be a greatly appreciated if you
could do that did I do it did I done so
it did every boy what kind of kind of
stupid-ass ski lift is there good to go
over here and then oh okay it's a
teleporting ski lift okay all right it's
some kind of magical okay then ski
school yeah sure we'd have to teach
people out of ski too cuz I'm not about
that
oh hi you owe your red hair
hey I'm Carrie I've taught just about
everyone here around here out of ski
it's not easy but with my help you'll
conquer the slopes and no wait why do I
have to ski no one told me that I was
gonna have to ski here everyone told me
that I was just gonna build ski lifts
and I thought that was the extent of it
because my engineering degree doesn't
cover skiing last time I went skiing I
fell down Brooke
with my help you'll conquer the slopes
in no time skier has encountered an
obstacle on the way down
crouch down load of improved and up tall
you know these these words don't help me
jump to early jump to late you're gonna
have a bad time okay all right cool
all righty then let's get some speed
going here what did blood shoot out of
my ankles wait a minute huh
am i okay Hermione's supposed to bend
that way
me sir all right fine man let's try this
again
not this not with the camera good well
going in blind here we go oh hey
apparently we call that a success around
these bars how do I get a follow cam on
this son of a [ __ ] Jimmy Starr I don't
want to go on Jimmy Starr Jimmy likes
shiny stars why are you talking about
yourself in the third person Jimmy Jimmy
okay they're scattered across the
mountain sometimes you must collect them
and deliver them to the top to pass a
level okay I'm right there with you
Jimmy all right sure what is this view
objectives now I don't need to worry
about that funk funk 'old all right WAMP
I like to get a nice incline going on my
tower got to get it higher higher going
one direction than it was originally
going the other way just to get some get
some extra oomph in there everybody
likes their ski towers with extra oomph
I've heard this on the radio sometimes
that's good enough
all right slap some wheels on that bad
boy Oh uncle Blanco and Bob's your uncle
we got a star going didn't need both of
those but you know I'm just gonna send
them for a loop-de-loop just give them a
couple of like a watt getting their
money's worth at least you know see
let's see what happens here I bet we're
gonna get the star though hey you have a
good we seem to have encountered our
first troubling issue here well there
goes oh they survived all right let's
try that and
no no one died no one died yet but we're
gonna hang this everybody just hold on
to yours so we obviously don't need this
I remember I delete things but I know
how to undo so let's just pretend like
this entire travesty was never dreamt up
by such a such a mind as me not quite
that high but this I that's how high we
need it oh yeah that's the good stuff
counterweights or something something
like that no no look good enough to me I
don't need that much wood well you know
overkill is my name and overkill is what
I do you know what actually you're it's
totally right I only need the one of
these don't I
huh again I don't know how to delete so
I guess this is gonna be here how do I
care
remember out it nope that was undo that
you there we go okay
selection ah get out of here no we can't
get out here get out of here okay all
right slap map flap okay and then
wibbly-wobbly whoo that's what I'm gonna
do got it
everybody come on I can't calm down
looks about right yeah okay
yeah it looks pretty pretty okay hey
they're not dead so what who'd have
thunk
there's a lot of pressure on that a
little bit wait maybe cuz the wheel
ain't exactly that will that don't seem
exactly right they're getting a little
counter offset to uh what I was supposed
to be doing over here but it's alright
it's okay Jimmy Starr is a raging
success all right here we go we got a we
got a ski now I don't know why is so
funny Jimmy we need to build a jump why
why you can build jumps just about
anywhere how why Jimmy Jimmy you're
you're not making no sense Jimmy Jimmy I
don't I don't understand what you are
talking about ah Jimmy all right
whatever man
all right you see jump move and zoom the
camera to focus on the building ah I'll
do a blindfolded just as good right yeah
I agree
okay all right zoom zoom zoom
that's a nice oh it's a sweet zoom you
know I think we need a bigger angle on
that the angle of that dangle just just
don't feel right there we go I know what
I'm - okay fine whatever
for you oh I see what here oh oh you
idiot I would knew that was gonna happen
sure okay all right all right sure all
right whatever we got it lean forward
lean back all right Carrie here we go
all right go buddy crouch lean I don't
know which way we're supposed to lean oh
oh
clearly pressing backwards oh we got
another one oh oh we don't even need to
do nothin to believe the level without
killing any riders well that doesn't
seem right at all Oh
what are you even doing why is this
advanced maybe because it doesn't go
anywhere maybe because this particular
ski lift just kind of goes off into
nothingness all right sure whatever you
know what I'm not gonna question what
you're talking about I'm just gonna go
for it
all right there's more to cheerless and
just playing some wheels what no don't
lie to me like this
don't make me feel so small the rope and
logs can be useful they have different
properties - planks logs are stronger
longer heavier and more expensive than
planks okay whatever once you get let's
put a long strong whoa I don't like the
way that grow oh yeah it's fine like
this no that's even more penile like but
something about how the logs there and
it's slightly like veiny looking it's
just ice throwing me off a little bit I
don't know why I can't explain it it's a
weird I don't know maybe I'm weird
probably all right well we got log got a
whole lot of log going on all right like
it ropes and logs and such cool sure all
right all righty then whap whap well I
don't need to do that but I'm doing it
anyway but hold onto your horses I like
how that one rope is just completely
slack something tells me Jimmy might let
me let me down the wrong path here if I
was a skier I don't know if I'd be too
trusting what's going on here mark stop
describing the logs please yeah I'm
gonna describe them even harder I'm
gonna describe their length and their
aptitude in their their shaft like
nature just in terms of vivid detail the
likes of which you'll never get out
mind em I know man Oh God that was just
that segment I feel like I've been
playing for 10 years oh no that's not
even the second and I did that's just
the warning okay
the warning all right good great and and
that's yeah this is all welp that didn't
work that's all you need right
righty-ho be okay slap it on there and
go B go B hurry up I know I'm gonna win
go okay cool
so what do I do about them oh there's
the problem child over there well okay I
think that'll do it that'll do it all
right what if we let's do it like this
yeah that's that looks more that looks
stable let's try that yeah here it is
I built the ultimate ski oh there he
goes his brains got gobbled up in there
real good like okay alright then anyway
so I'm gonna just clear all that I don't
have logs
I can't log this up I only got planks
thin unger the-- planks that's all I got
so you know what yeah we're gonna try it
up like this all this style and such
we're gonna give it one of the old these
treatments it's gonna be an expensive
one but you know at least it's gonna be
safe and that's what that's what I
that's what I prioritize your mark Larry
its cues here we go the safety Aslam so
safe everybody hop on the safety mobile
here we go
go a little faster there at least try
something tells me I'm I'm making it a
bit too heavy
I seem to have completely ignored all
the lessons taught to me from the
tutorial there we go this is gonna dis
the wow there's the one oh you know
there's the one easy peasy up like it's
nothing who'd have thought that I was
birth to hit the ground a little bit
there but you know oh god no you know
the warning might have been might have
been an indicative of
about what was just gonna was success
hey know what Dad
oh well that one may be dead don't think
the knees are supposed to go that way
but because you hit that sign you should
you pay attention to the sign it's
clearly there for your protection
death by warning yeah I like that that's
it seems great within the specified
budget yep you know me I always reach a
budget when it comes to safety standards
all right yeah give it to me there we go
okay I'm done that's good luck for that
one oh I still see the outline of his
corpse over there by that lock
[Music]